>> Sean: I'VE BEEN TRYING
TO TELL YOU I CAN'T CONVEY
IN WORDS THE URGENCY I
FEEL.
THE MIDTERMS, AND WHAT IT
MEANS FOR THE COUNTRY IN
FIVE DAYS.
HERE WITH REACTION, OUR
FRIEND, TIM SCOTT.
HE HAS DONE A PHENOMENAL
JOB, TRAVELED AROUND THE
COUNTRY ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU BACK,
SENATOR.
HERE WE ARE, FIVE DAYS TO
GO.
CLOSING ARGUMENTS.
DEMOCRATS ARE DESPERATE.
THEY SAY ALL REPUBLICANS
WANT TO CUT SOCIAL
SECURITY, MEDICARE, VA
BENEFIT.
THAT'S A LIE, NOT ONE
PERSON IS ADVOCATING THAT
AND THEY SEEM DESPERATE.
>> I SMELL DESPERATION IN
THE AIR.
SEAN, YOU'RE RIGHT WHAT
YOU SAID IN THE MONDAY
DOING IS SO IMPORTANT.
IT IS CRYSTAL CLEAR.
IF WE ARE TO WIN THE
MAJORITY IN THE SENATE, IT
TAKES EVERY SINGLE VOTER
IN A BATTLEGROUND STATE
WHO IS SICK AND TIRED OF
BEING SICK AND TIRED.
REPUBLICANS, DEMOCRATS,
INDEPENDENTS, SHOW UP AND
VOTE FOR THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE.
REMEMBER THIS, SEAN, IN
STATE OF GEORGIA, JANUARY
5th, 2021, LOSS OF A
SINGLE SENATE SEAT COST
THE AMERICAN TAXPAYERS
MORE THAN DOLLARS.
THAT COULD BE HELD BY
GENERAL DON BOLDUC, A
PATRIOT.
WINNING IN NEW HAMPSHIRE
MAY BE THE STATE THAT
TAKES US ACROSS AND GIVES
US THE MAJORITY.
IN GEORGIA, NORTH
CAROLINA, OHIO, WISCONSIN,
WE HAVE TO WIN.
NEVADA.
ARIZONA.
EVERY SINGLE VOTER HEAR ME
CLEARLY.
YOUR VOTE MATTERS TODAY
MORE THAN IT HAS EVER
MATTERED.
WE MUST FINISH THIS RACE.
DON'T RUN TO THE FINISH
LINE, RUN THROUGH THE
FINISH LINE.
THERE'S TOO MUCH AT STAKE.
I UNDERSTAND THE POWER OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
>> Sean: DON'T FORGET
PENNSYLVANIA AND THE STATE
OF WASHINGTON EITHER.
>> TIFFANY SMILEY, SPOKE
WITH HER DAY BEFORE
YESTERDAY, SHE'S CLOSING
THE GAP.
WE'RE SENDING MORE
RESOURCES HER WAY BECAUSE
WE KNOW THE RED WAVE IS
COMING, BUT IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN BY ITSELF.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE FROM
SEA TO SHINING SEA WE SHOW
UP, GET VOTERS OUT, MAKE
SURE YOU CALL YOUR
FRIENDS.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE ONE,
LINDSEY GRAHAM SAYS MAKE
ONE TODAY.
WE NEED EVERY SINGLE VOTER
SHOWING UP, SHOWING OUT.
WE WILL HAVE A MAJORITY IN
THE SENATE.
A 25 SEAT MAJORITY IN THE
HOUSE AND RESTORE SANITY
TO THE GREATEST NATION ON
GOD'S GREEN EARTH.
LET'S GET IT DONE.
>> Sean: IF REPUBLICANS
WIN, SENATOR, YOU HAVE
BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
POWERFUL ADVOCATES FOR SO
MANY PEOPLE, A BIG PART OF
THEIR SUCCESS WILL BE
BECAUSE OF YOUR HARD WORK
AND